I always try to find some sort of
interesting image that can be used for
these caption contests where I post
something and then say hey come up with
some sort of funny or interesting or
thoughtful quip about this and in this
picture you see The Sassy Cat long since
gone
unfortunately looking at Loa Comics
obviously not reading it because she
unfortunately was not literate and
probably wouldn't have had the patience
to read even a comic book anyway but she
loved books and would often get her nose
in there so let's see what people had to
say about this we begin with some puns
and I'll let you decide whether these
are good or not so we have first modus
pawnin obviously playing off of The
Logical argumentation structure modus
pins we have another paw related one
pause for thought then read on and then
uh again fits in quite well with the
context prinkipia meow matica playing
off pipia Mathematica one of the texts
that is mentioned within loic Comics
then we have another set of let's call
them jokes about logic and these are
taking ideas about cats and putting them
into some sort of logical structure so
we have if it were true that all cats
are black and white it would necessarily
follow that all non black and white
things are not cats and the other one if
I was a cat then I wouldn't be reading a
book I am reading a book therefore I am
not a cat which is modus tolins right
and it's interesting
because sassy isn't black and white
she's actually white and gray but it I
suppose it looks black in this uh photo
so moving on we get a bunch of quips
that are playing off of stereotypes of
cats as thinking that they're Superior
to all other animals and not being all
that sociable so first one this Pavlov
sounds like an interesting but misguided
fellow I just walk near my food dish
hungry or not and my servant jumps to
feed me okay so that's not too bad
here's another one nothing about world
domination here again playing off of the
notion that cats think that they are
superior to all other creatures and are
either secretly aiming at world
domination and actually planning it or
desire it but are too lazy to bring it
about then we get a few more about
owners prep to debate with owner on how
it is better for convenience to buy more
boxes and treats as we know cats will
stuff themselves into boxes including
even big cats like lions and tigers it's
quite comical to see that and of course
cats do love treats then we get another
one for once the fool bought some mildly
interesting reading material the fool
being me of course uh Sassy's owner I
didn't actually buy the book though it
was a gift from one of my friends who
thought I would enjoy it and indeed I
did and I've since passed it on to one
of my kids then we get away from the
let's say lwh hanging fruit and we get I
I would say some clever uh quips so this
is one I I particularly like how shall I
spend the rest of my lives cats you know
by folklore have nine lives and
apparently sassy is spending one of them
reading here's another one the existence
of cat girls necessarily implies the
existence of tuna boys but where are
they I suppose this is supposed to be
like a thought bubble over Sassy's head
and it's strange to think of her knowing
about catg girls but there you go now
tuna boys never heard of that but we
could imagine what is it like a boy made
out of tuna a boy who resembles a tuna
uh you know there there could be all
sorts of variations on that and then we
get one that's a little bit more uh
timely and topical no sassy I said I was
featured in existential Comics different
Series so not logic Comics but
existential comics where very recently
um the the artist commemorated my
finishing the half hour Hegel series
after nine and a half years by putting
me into the comic strip as a character
and then finally here's here's a great
one it is a bit of a pun
and I think you'll recognize the
statement is coming from lud Vicken
Stein's tradus logico philosophicus
whereof one cannot meow thereof one must
be silent so that's a great close to
this we do these caption contests every
so often uh so if you're interested in
getting in on it you probably want to
turn your uh notification tab on and
check my community tab in my YouTube
Channel I also post these in social
media so if you're following me in
Twitter Facebook LinkedIn or Mastadon
you'll probably see them as well if
you're paying attention so um until next
time that is it for this
one